No, it was a dangerous place.
Thank you very much.
This is an eye
nail doll.  First, please choose
a filter.He's a very aristocratic person.Big race
beer.Horibei Minami
Ward.Those who are still evolving are also skilled Shinkansen kids.
Ha Tasso, after all, when we
're walking together,
monsters rarely attack me
.
It hurts,
two of you are okay Did your
parents get killed?
I
've got to improve my eyesight Dwarf, you're embarrassed On top of that, they're going
to make a fuss and run away The Pacific Giant Ape
just looks scary, and people don't like it, but
have you both lost your edge
?  If you don't mind, you
can ride along with me
Don't negotiate with
me for just
one lyric
.
If
you do, of course,
I'll introduce you to approval with a certain
degree
.
Even if I say a little about my origins,
they won't
believe
me.  Even if I say it, it seems like it will only happen 5 times
.